de blasio to phase out new york city
gifted and talented program this is a
new york times story
he on friday he unveiled a plan to
overhaul gifted and talented education
new york city elementary schools calling
for sweeping changes to a highly
selective program that has been widely
criticized for exas exacerbating
segregation in the nation's largest
school system the mayor's action attempt
to address what the city has known for
decades it's gifted and talented program
has controlled to racially segregated
classrooms and schools for thousands of
students nationwide citywide de blasio
has criticized for not taking forceful
action to fulfill his promise of
tackling inequality in public schools
the announcement comes just three months
before he must leave office because of
term limits putting the fate of the plan
in the hands of his successor adam
thoughts so let me get this straight he
just wants everyone in the new york city
school system just to be in regular
classes yeah no that would be an honors
so as someone who has taken regular
classes
uh something called academic excellence
i've been in honors classes and i've
been ap classes
for anyone that's ever been in school
knows that's a huge freaking difference
to give you a case example i was by far
and away the smartest person
in regular classes when i took them and
i was by far away the dumbest person in
ap classes when i took those classes so
i had to like find my bearings i had to
figure out like i was actually pretty
good at history i couldn't read so good
so i had to get into regular like the
fact that you're just gonna lump
everyone are you saying into one class
are you saying you wish you would have
never taken any ap classes so you
wouldn't have felt inferior no no no
it's it's you gotta understand that
bottom line is i think this is a
horrible idea i don't know if they're
looking for equality or uh what's the
term that everyone's using the diversity
equity including maybe inclusive on a
serious note how did it feel when you
went i've never taken ap i've never
taken honors on 1.8 esl lifelong esl efl
when you went from uh regular class to
ap and honors what what did you feel as
a student well
look
when i was in regular classes so i i
went from public school my whole life
and then i
got a scholarship so i was in private
school last few years so they just kind
of were like you did good in public
school we're going to throw you in
honors classes all across the board at a
school called miami country day in miami
and it's a it's kind of like a
westminster it's a good school
and i realized oh [ __ ] i i i remember
some friends over there we had a hedge
fund guy over that's extremely
successful in greenwich and they were
trying to put their kids in miami
country they and they were raving about
the school grade school yeah i'm very
like lifelong contacts great but the
point is this i realized very quickly i
was good at some stuff
and not good at other stuff and then i
went down to regular and the bottom line
is this
i don't understand this idea
kids work their asses off to excel in
school now you're gonna have super super
smart kids just sitting there
literally dumbfounded being in regular
classes i think this is a horrible idea
so is that so basically are they saying
that the curriculum will not be ap
is that right
apparently
making it easier making it easier for
you to not feel inferior to others who
are so they don't want us to compete
yeah yeah that's exactly what it is and
i think essentially that's wrong so if
you put yourself in the
like let's let's look at both sides of
the coin who are the kids that are like
i feel you know inferior i feel like i'm
being not included in the smart kids so
i protect my feelings and put everyone
in my class that's that kid i guess or
the probably not even the kid their
parents i would assume now think about
the kid that's like look i'm working my
freaking ass off here i read every
single night i'm strategizing i'm
improving my kids my parents have raised
me right and now you want me to go to
the just
regular
class how does that help me how does
that get me ap credits
here's what makes no sense here's what
i'm thinking about
which kid actually wants this like look
i'm the other kid right i'm the kid at
the bottom of the
uh uh what do you call it like you know
how you listen
i'm the bottom of the regular closet
yeah so like like not the be like you're
saying you were the best in the regular
class i'm the bottom of the regular
class okay right you're not excelling i
wonder if they did this would this make
me feel more confident would this make
me feel more special would this make me
feel more like oh my gosh thank you so
much for doing this because i was
feeling very you know weak
i don't even think those kids get hair
yeah but go and think about do those
kids even care you're still gonna grade
on a curve right that's the kid's still
gonna get a deer and i say that because
gerard and i both wrote this
exactly i just wrote it just now and you
wrote it yeah you're going to still the
smartest kids are going to get a's
are going to yeah
it goes beyond that it goes beyond that
guys i mean what's happening here is you
know the white savior complex this is
you know the white liberal activist
who's you know she's in class and she's
the teacher and she's like well if every
kid just had the resources that
these kids in the ap classes had they'd
all have the same capacity they're they
are completely and totally
incapable of seeing differences between
human beings they're incapable in seeing
that some people may excel in a and not
excel and b all it is is access to to
opportunity and the resources and we'll
all be exactly the same we'll it will
create nothing but a land of square pegs
and square holes it's nonsense i mean
really what it comes down to is it shows
what education public education
specifically in this country is man it's
it's it's it's an indoctrination camp it
has nothing to do with education has
nothing to do with improving the
intellectual capacity of our next
generations in fact i'd argue that they
are putting obedience ahead of education
all they want to do is herd these people
into classes and indoctrinate them
politically on what they should think
they don't teach people how to think
anymore which is really all ap classes
do ap classes now you're talking about
logic now you're talking about
philosophy now you're talking about they
offer
yes okay so okay i'm assuming you not
all not all well you don't take honors
in ap classes here's the difference all
right in regular history class they
teach you what happened in ap history
they ask you why it happened and that is
the difference that's the major
difference okay the major difference is
this is what happened on these dates
regurgitate this get it get it right on
the test so our school can get money
from the state there you go in ap
it's you're already graded on a higher
curve you can have a 5.0 instead of a
4.0 so a b student in ap is still a 4.0
student okay so they already get the
money from the state and it's a small
amount of students that you know get
into this is that that other side of the
bell curve
but they ask you these are the people
that they start asking questions why
okay and i feel like in this environment
not to be crazy conspiracy theory
these people do not want kids learning
how to ask the question why
they do not want a generation of people
asking why this is happening why we're
doing things this way they want people
that understand obedience above all else
well this is just the new york city it's
not all this it's not though it's it's
the first time around it's the start
it's the first domino to fall i mean
you can do the same thing you think
other school systems across the country
are going to implement this in math how
about this the fact that harvard was
caught
by having completely different uh
admission standards
predicated on your nationality yeah
asian kids white kids and then everybody
else after that right where that you had
you had to score so remarkably higher
than other people to get in all right
the social stratification man like i i
again it goes back to everything that
we're talking about and also on a side
note bill de blasio first mayor in 100
years to not have a professional sports
team win a championship in new york city
i don't think that that is look it it's
an interesting coincidence but it goes
again like excellence is not something
that they want and it's amazing that
whenever we're talking about equality
whenever we're talking about inclusion
it's never about lifting people up it's
always about ripping people down of
course they're trying to get everybody
to instead of okay
easiest way to put it we want you all to
blend in with each other instead of
stand out
you're supposed to have standouts so
what you're saying is they encourage
these people fan their flames push them
push them push them because you don't
want to be the stumble bum is what we
would say back in you know my day you
know
which means like you're going to be one
on the corner doing stupid [ __ ] well pal
i mean you definitely got to focus on
these things because it's very
imperative that and what about the kids
that want to excel
and get college credit while they're in
high school my younger brother did that
he was phi theta kappa at 16 years old
so he was exceptional right who's
pushing for this well should there be
varsity sports i mean what's the next
logical right everyone just should there
be varsity sports you just get the nerd
getting pummeled by gerard in high
school that's fun but i'm just saying
varsity is ap sports
right right i mean what's why why if
we're if everything is going to be
exactly the same then why isn't
everything exactly the same
why is it only about these these this is
where my spidey senses start to tingle
why is it only about dumbing down and
indoctrinating the future
that's when i start to say man is this
an effective strategy is this an
effective strategy though so let's just
say that is your outcome let's just say
that's your outcome and you're trying to
dumb him down
do you think okay so do you think the
guy that's going to make it out is going
to make it out do you think the guy
that's going to be a standout is going
to be a standard you can't do nothing to
them i think that their argument their
argument is that we're not going to
divert the resources to a small section
of people we're going to give those
resources to everybody no but i'm not
asking you that what i'm asking you is
do you think the guy that's gonna make
it is gonna make it whether they do this
or not i think what's gonna happen is
twofold you're gonna have people like
adam said that are so bored in these
classes that they check out and you're
gonna have people that the conversation
is so high above them that they check
out so i think that you're going to have
an opportunity really for khan academy
or some secondary educational school
where auto diadex are going to have to
start
auto
auto diadex people that are study on
their own they're self-taught they're
self-educated they're going to have to
seek out their own their own path and
it's going to happen on both ends you
know i got a buddy of mine jamie
mcdermott one of my one of my best
friends in the world he was never dumb
but he was always misinterested he was
just disinterested in school just
disinterested never wanted to do
anything all he wanted to do was talk to
chicks the whole time if it wasn't for
sports he would have never gone to to
class at all then he he goes to college
and something clicks and he's like you
know what man i got to get my [ __ ]
together now the dude's got an mba and
he works at fitch like he's crushing it
but similar to yourself if he had a 2.0
gpa in high school it was a lot like he
just didn't care you know what i'm
saying so in this environment pushing
him along might work for a guy like jay
because he doesn't get left behind but
in these and
correct me if i'm wrong every class is
different like i said i went i was in
dumb math but in smart history what have
you
everyone excels at different things like
you like you're talking were you good in
math was math math it was not i was good
up until a certain point then when you
started throwing trigonometry and
geometry i'm like i'm out this is this
is did you take this analysis
uh i don't recall if i took that i i
crushed it normal stuff like addition
subtraction multiplication and then when
they started throwing
x and theorem and also
i was like you know we're never gonna
use this [ __ ] like i was that kid in the
background like why are we doing this
make sense can i just go like play
football but the point is that some
people excel in certain classes some
people don't
so
if you're going to put everyone in the
same class same thing
like that
in in itself
whether it's sports whether it's uh
woodshop all right we're all doing it
whoever does you know
but
in each class each subject to put
everyone they have a heart in the same
thing make sure that the future was more
important than the curriculum the
teacher if the teacher made it
interesting if the teacher made it
you know
the material engaging
then
everybody was involved like like whether
or not we were good at math or liked
math it depended on the teacher i had a
teacher that made math into money and
baseball statistics and we were all
totally great but then we had another
teacher who was like sit there shut up
and read the book so let's go back to it
let's go back to it so the question is
will this
do anything to the guy that's going to
make it anyways does this affect the
standout guy i think it does you think
so
you always hear these talented people we
always hear it in sports but it could be
in academics as well these talented
people that
did something went wrong i fully agree
with them i fully agree let me tell you
i agree with you guys you guys know the
story of nick boleteri you know nick
boleteer the tennis coach yeah the
tennis coach yeah of course do you know
who he is like have you met him yes yes
he's in town in south florida yeah he
isn't down south florida he's the
teacher okay all my friends so let me
tell you who this guy is how do you
describe him
his students his students
any of the students that went to his
camp how many champions how many grand
slams do you think they want all his
students
180 grand slam winners came out 180
total grand slams he coaches i think
you're a family member andre andre
agassi was his phenom anyway so there's
a story there's a documentary about this
guy there's a documentary about this guy
where
he's uh coaching players right and he's
coaching jimmy connors and he's coaching
agassi and they're going back and forth
the story then goes to a story of a two
girls that he was coaching
one of the girls is coming up and she's
crushing it she's kicking ass 11 years
old she's going to be the youngest you
know to go out and compete all the stuff
that's taking place with her and then
all of a sudden the father comes up and
the father says nick i want you to drop
everybody because the father was a very
very rich like billionaire and he says i
want you to drop everybody i just want
you to coach my daughter he's like i
can't do that i got 100 kids here it's
not my business model he said i'll pay
you whatever you want he says you don't
understand that's not my business mod he
says i will pay how much you make money
i'm gonna make you dismiss i don't want
the money i want to coach the kids
anyways the pops gets pissed he says i'm
out of here so he leaves the daughter is
telling the story the girl that could
have been
she says when my dad took me says don't
worry about it we'll go find another
coach they go to another coach lower
standards they go to another coach low
stand the dad kept telling their
daughter don't worry about it this guy's
good for you this guy's good for you
this guy's good for the girls like i
eventually became a nobody if i would
have stayed with nick i would have been
a top three right and the whole story
with nick is standards and expectation
high high standards and expectation
people rise up agassi courier sellers
uh uh what he called the the sisters all
of those guys went through him right
what's the moral of the story here drop
the standards i believe that 12 to me it
goes back to the same thing the 12
percent that has what it takes to
dominate but they don't get the right
challenge they're not pushed they're not
challenged to do more somebody's not
tough on it where the expectations are
you're going to lose that 12 percent so
i think this actually affects i agree
those guys i fully believe teachers
matter coaches i don't think it's just
teachers because remember even nick
wasn't the one that was teaching
everybody
nick had 40 teachers that were teaching
putting together a program i think it's
a system of standards yes i think it's a
set of standards and protocols when you
have a certain set of high expectations
and standards one of two things going to
happen to you here's what happens
you're either going to respond to it or
you're going to hate this guy forever
they kept telling stories of two people
two guys and two girls agassi and jimmy
connors right agassi was his phenom
guess who's the only person that didn't
want to do an interview on this on this
documentary agassi is the only guy that
refused to do the interview all the
other people agreed to do it why
wouldn't agassi do who didn't do well
with him is the people that hated high
standards agassi hated it and this other
girl hated it but jimmy connors loved it
so jimmy connors won eight grand slams
the uh the people that like high
standards they responded to it when you
have high standards and expectations
this is what you produce this is always
going to happen
what is the what is the most annoying
thing
about a great example
when it's right what's the most annoying
thing about having a leader that's got a
great example
it's a great freaking example it sucks
it absolutely sucks because you're like
the hell with you so much pressure i
don't want to have to live up to this
expectation but what's the best thing
about having a guy like that he can push
you yep but regardless not everybody's
going to fit to those standards correct
you're still going to produce some
people that are going to be resenting it
and coming out and saying you know what
screw you i hate that teacher everybody
had that one coach that later on they
hate her but deep down inside they're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
you know that guy really had me he had
really challenged me we all have that
right i think this is a this is a
travesty what they're doing to the kids
there because there could be a few
phenoms that we're going to find out
about 10 20 30 40 years from now that
we're probably gonna lose but i still
think that there's a small percentage of
people put them at one percent two
percent small percentage they're going
to figure out a way to kill you
the law of unintended consequences
something all these commies refuse to
admit exists man
all it's going to take now is that
wealthy people or even middle class
people are going to put their kids in
into private school where you could have
had your kids
communicating networking learning from
these other people who were gifted and
then rise picking each other up like
you're talking about now what you're
gonna have is you're gonna have this
again this for social stratification
this segregation where it's like i can't
have my kid in the school i can't have
my kids in the world people are already
putting their kids in private sure new
york
but part of the reason why that you but
but again we're thinking well you're not
wealthy you're not from a wealthy family
but you're thinking i got a scholarship
no no no no no of course what i'm trying
to say is i don't want to lose you but
you're you're the one i don't want to
lose the guy that is a phenom the guy
that is a guy that needs somebody to
challenge him because he'll respond to
it in manhattan they've already been in
private schools but in queens they they
haven't been in staten island they
haven't been
in in brooklyn a lot of parts of
brooklyn they're not you got lincoln
lafayette you got some i mean
you this is the first this is what your
city texas has anybody ever tried to
implement
well what happens is they they
what they tried to do which was probably
wrong in the other direction is that
they had like gifted schools where they
took the entire like gifted student
and then they put them in in gifted
schools which probably wasn't right in
its own right so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]